نشاهد هذه صور جديده بثتها سرايا القدس
لما قالت انها مشاهد من عمليه وصفتها
بالنوعيه استهدفت خلالها موقع قياده
وسيطره الجيش الاسرائيلي جنوب محور
الزيتون
نشاهد
[موسيقى]
b
شاهدون
التجمع عدد كبير من الخيام وخوات
الجله كما تشاهدون
امامكم
الجنود كم
تشاهدون الان تجهيز يوم سب على بياره ابو
[موسيقى]
ردان بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم سيتم الان اطلاق عشق صاروخيه
باتجاه تحشد
[موسيقى]
الان
لله اييب
والله الله
اكبر
الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله
[موسيقى]
اكبر
الله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
p
من يوم السبت الموافق
30 12 2023 كما تشهدون الان هروب عدد كبير
من الجبات العسكريه من داخل تجمع بربان
باتجاه الشرق كما تشاهدون امامكم بعد
استهدافه ب برشقه صاروخيه وعدد من قذائف
الهاون من قبل الوحده المدفعيه لسرايا
القدس
[موسيقى]
oh